joining us from the athletic uh terrific
reporting as always and lots going on
here in los angeles in particular um
with the lake or sam amick uh back here
on the rich eisen show how you doing sam
rich doing great good morning sir so um
can you let me know when there's big
meetings at the lakers front office
because that's just right around the
corner i could bring him donuts i could
bring him coffee
i could put my ear to the ground i could
do all that that happened tuesday just
like six days ago down the street from
us here sam i could be they did
they should have included some of
lebron's branded tequila just to lighten
the mood a little bit well i mean it
doesn't well sam i got to tell you i
don't know i don't know if
the mood needed to be lightened because
from your article i've written the quote
down here uh they were quote unquote
laughing and catching up they were
laughing and catching yeah they got
there they got there it's interesting i
mean it was damage control mode in my
opinion um just such a fascinating
like 10-day stretch roughly you know and
then for me
rich you know you got to start with
their
terrible loss in milwaukee
uh before the all-star break if you
remember
you know you've been doing this for so
long at such a high level that you know
you're very good at connecting dots so
it's not a real coincidence
that that night lebron announces
publicly that they're just not on the
box level
and then that same night there's i think
at least three
reports that were very similar that were
sourced from the locker room that the
lakers players do not believe this
roster is good enough
um you know it kind of starts there and
then you know you guys capped a few of
the things
before i jumped on as far as like the
different messages coming from
lebron it's the tweets it's the sam
presley comments all the above the
interview about cleveland um
you know and then just got messier and
messier so the meeting i think was just
to
obviously calm the waters and
and get this thing back in a productive
place uh didn't look that way last night
but but they've been trying well there's
one thing that's missing and i'll i'll
ask you if
anybody knows what it is if you know
what it is and you're willing or you can
share it
is there had to have been
a trade during the trade deadline
that lebron either caught wind of knew
about or rich paul caught window of or
knew about ear to the ground
that um that
polinka said no to
and that um
and and that's part of what happened
behind the scenes
or am i am i just that's a false
assumption no i mean i i have pressed on
that specific question with people who
would know and the answer i got was and
i tried to write this that it was
a little more holistic that they you
know lebron looks at other teams and
you know okay a guy like austin reeves
has had some good moments you know malik
monk's been a good find but but they
need more of that on this roster since
you don't have assets and you couldn't
be aggressive trade wise they should
have found a way to you know dwight
howard and andre jordan are kind of for
the most part taking up roster spots at
this point not playing as much as they
thought they would
but in terms of a specific trade this is
just me talking i would not be surprised
if
like yes i feel like and lebron's never
going to admit this or talk openly about
it but the russell westbrook
john wall
possibility
was
was obviously available to them and
there was two iterations of it one was
you give houston your 2027 first round
pick and i do truly believe that lebron
and his associates
you know obviously including rich paul
support the lakers decision and feel
like that would have been unwise to give
houston the first but then we learned
that okay well you could have got it
done if you did pick swap so you don't
lose your pick you just get the worst of
the two picks down the road and this
this is the part where it's just me
talking like if i had to guess lebron
probably thinks they should have pulled
the trigger on that but again that's
just me and and then with john wall in
particular another kind of factor that i
was told was that because he hasn't
played all year the lakers had either
uneasy about you know investing anything
i mean they at least know what russell
westbrook is
and so there wasn't a ton of confidence
that john wall was going to come in and
be a game changer and they felt like uh
you know that so they said no to that
but
in terms of specific deals that's kind
of the only one that people really talk
about yeah because that that's
where in my mind robert meets road and
why why same pages can be found right
um is that
now that this has been a conversation
that's been had and the laughing and
catching up went down or what have you
there had to be a conversation about
what happens once the
the summer hits right i mean there has
to be that sort of conversation about
what now what next
what is something that lebron expects or
what's something that polinka is
thinking about and how that could all be
on the same page right like so what is
the fix what is the
the the future the next steps yeah i
mean admittedly that's where i don't
have clarity i have a feel for
the vibe and the vibe you know it feels
to me like on the lebron side of things
you know i i mean okay he might have
sent not by them he sent all these
strong messages
passive aggressive aggressive aggressive
all of the above
but then
i do feel as if he
you know
when he came out of the all-star break
and he got back in the locker room with
the lakers there was a recalibration
there where he was not willing to burn
the bridge entirely it does seem pretty
clear to me that like i said earlier
there was a damage control intent
uh even having the meeting shows that
much now what it means for the summer
we shall see of course august 4th he can
sign a two-year extension
and um you know and that's where the
question becomes what does he want for
his future you know even independent of
the conversation about
his son and whether or not he'll play
with briani i think you know i mean my
goodness rich
last night they not only get
played off the floor by the pelicans i
just a few minutes ago watch some of the
social media stuff from behind the
lakers bench i mean you've got trevor
ariza russell westbrook getting into it
with fans lebron's chirping with fans
while he's in the middle of the game the
blue birds were out genie busts left
when they were at least appeared to
leave when they were down like 25 points
left her seat and went through the
tunnel um just an ugly scene so if
you're lebron it just becomes can you
fix it and if not are you going to do
something else and head out well what's
the do something else i mean how how do
you see that if
you know again
there's a conversation to be had
about what picks to if you will f
in the future that keeps lebron happy
right
and then if that doesn't materialize
then lebron will say f this and want to
hit whatever but how does that work you
have to find a partner and then again
lebron's contract extension the the two
years doesn't match up when brawny would
come out a one in a one plus one would
right like that that right walk me
through what what that plan b might
might look like
here in l.a yeah i mean it's hard to say
this without knowing the market
elsewhere i mean you know at face value
you feel confident saying
it's lebron ramon james right and he's
still playing i mean probably a shade
below mvp caliber level
his numbers are incredible right not
showing an ability to to will them to
actually win games but he's playing you
know he's not the problem this year
um so
you've got a lot of teams that are going
to be interested but what's the price
tag going to be if they decide you know
mutually to
to do something i don't know what that
looks like i also think
and you're you know i think you're
probably extremely well-versed in this
having covered the lakers for a long
time like how interesting is this
dynamic in the context of lakers history
lakers culture
you know genie bust the way she was
raised by her father to run this thing
yes they are a star friendly culture
they also traded shaquille o'neal when
they thought that was crude
they have made other tough choices
before
i do feel like
there is a bit of a
kind of a cat and mouse game happening
right now between the two sides where
they're deciding what they think of one
another at this stage of the
relationship and so that's where you
know you can't read genie's mind but you
know is she thinking about uh moving
past this chapter i don't know i i think
she's pretty
pragmatic and she's you know shown an
ability to make tough choices before so
i wouldn't take that off the table
and that's where i think they have to
see
how the end of the season wraps up see
what the possibilities are in the summer
in terms of the roster and then go from
there yeah i'll be honest i mean i know
kobe uh rested soul before he passed
told her that she needed to be like the
mother of dragons right when she makes
these types of decisions
but i also think you know what what the
lakers would love to have is why
wouldn't the lakers it's it's so on
brand for them to want to have lebron
finish his career here let him have his
griffy season with his son here
while
spending whatever picks need to be spent
to get a championship roster for his
dotage years here and and
sell the jerseys and get the attention
and have all of those ceremonies like
that's that's their brand right don't
you think it is sam it is but i mean for
one it's you know sell all those picks i
mean really by the time this summer
comes around we are talking about two
first round picks i believe 2027 and
2029 like
you know that's not getting you another
star um that might get you off of russ
westbrook that will get you off of
russell westbrook but you know that's i
don't i don't see a path currently
toward a title-worthy roster and then
the other thing i guess to give a hat
tip to a colleague of mine who has
certainly had a very uh interesting
couple days is bill orem who covers the
legend of the athletic had
reported
this kind of it didn't fly under the
radar but i don't think it got enough
credit um
his understanding in terms of the lakers
view of this thing
is that lebron and clutch
at this point
have
more influence and more sway
than kobe even did and that's such an
incredible statement um and to me that's
where it comes back to jeannie and it's
like what's her comfort level if in fact
that is the the kind of the feel and the
vibe and the read of the room
i think there's a fair question of like
you know lebron we want you here and
yeah we'd love it if you finish your
career here and all these things but you
know if if if you think you're going to
run the entire franchise and take
complete control of this thing that's
not happening no i mean well i mean
because a clutch has anthony davis too
and that's the reason why anthony davis
is there is because of lebron and clutch
let's be honest and that's what's kind
of crazy um sam amick of the athletic
here is that they got wiped
that floor wiped um with them by the
team that they acquired anthony davis
from you know what i'm saying and so
yeah um
man there's just so much to talk about
here on the lakers front but i do want
to move
right now to the eastern conference
first blush the um harden acquisition
appears to put the the sixers on quite a
trajectory how do you think this is
going to play out over the next several
weeks
yeah they look really good um you know
it's funny i i texted a
a buddy of mine in the business uh mo
dakil from bleacher report had written a
bunch of stuff saying that he had x's
and o's concerns about the
hardened embed
pairing and it was a smart analysis
breaking down why it might not be as
great as people would assume so
naturally i had to give them a hard time
when it looked so good after two games
like i don't know man they they look
pretty damn dangerous and
in it the vibe is seemingly very good
james harden it really is you know say
what you will about how he left houston
how he left brooklyn
when he's in a good place and we'll see
if it continues
um this guy is special and even
you can see it in the zip on his passes
and even kind of the way he's bouncing
down the floor a bit he's obviously
having a lot of fun here in the early
stages
and
kind of reminding people that he is on
that short list of elite talents in this
league so they look dangerous it's only
a couple games we'll see how it goes
from here but i like
you know the trade for them and like you
guys were talking about earlier the
parody in the east is it's just insane
because you can you know just kind of
pick a team and throw a dart at the
dartboard and you're probably going to
get it right in terms of somebody being
a contender there's
so many really really good teams well i
mean there there's the heat at the top
of it we're looking at a game in front
of the bulls and demar derozan what a
run that he has been on
uh cavs bucks sixers right there
um just two and a half behind the heat
and again the thing is about the
hardin's first two games sam
is
you know embiid said after friday night
he's never been more wide open in his
career
and then and then
i can't help but notice the first two
games that hardin's been there tyrese
maxie has been a hell of a third man in
here
it's not just a two-man game you know
this kid has had a has lit it up the
last two nights
as well he's been fantastic yeah and
even that i mean my goodness like how
great has this or how well has this
worked out
for daryl mori the sixers president of
basketball operations because if you go
back to when daryl
was trying to trade poor james harden
with houston
you know kyrie's maxi i believe at that
point was part of the discussion that
just wasn't the guy that he is now and
you know there was a there was a world
that existed where you you kind of sent
him along because he was you know
you kind of saw him as expendable at the
time and now to see
the kind of player he's become where he
gives you
a third you know impact guy is huge and
it's just it is again it's wild to watch
i mean james i don't know what quarter
it was he had a pass the other night
where you know from behind half court
just a chest pass to a runner on the
right side and i was thinking to myself
you know i wish they had a you know an
odometer on that thing or a speed gun
because it just had more zip on it than
any hardened pass that i'd seen in quite
some time and i thought it spoke to how
locked in he was so they're dangerous
you know it is tough that they had to
lose seth curry in that deal they would
be
you know even better from a shooting
front if that was the case if they still
had them but they're really good
last one for you sam amick of the
athletic what is your reporting on zion
and what's going on and the fact that cj
mccollum has not
really connected with him and um and
whether there's something up with zion
and the pelicans and
his future
there in doubt yeah i mean tough to read
and handicap it you know um
a brutal couple days where his former
teammate j.j redick was sharing just
really candid perspective about diane on
on a huge stage at espn
now cj to be fair has updated the
situation and now claims that zion
did reach out to him but it's a terrible
look that it comes you know 10 days
after he was traded to new orleans or
whatever it was
so i mean zion working out in portland
trying to
you know get himself in a good place you
know that that um decision reportedly
was one that he came to mutually with
the team so it's not as if he's just
completely going rogue and going places
where the team didn't greenlight it but
you know listen we all know where we
feel like this is going you know reports
for quite some time that his family
just doesn't want him to play there but
it's it's unfortunate because right now
you look at what the pelicans are doing
and if he was healthy which i don't
think he is but if he was there i mean
this is this is maybe a you know top
four top five team in the west if you
add zion to it given the way they're
playing the last two weeks they got a
lot of potential but you know that's not
going to be uh happening anytime soon
all right so as i send you out the door
what do you think the story of the next
four weeks in the league's going to be
um
what do you you know crystal ball it um
crystal ball what do you think i got
recently biased because i was up late
last night writing about the west i mean
i i you know i know this is not as high
profile or
doesn't necessarily move the needle but
the denver nuggets are really good and
they might be getting jamal murray and
michael porter jr back before the
playoffs um
so we talk about the east having parody
i mean i guess the story
down the home stretch is parody we got
parody in the east and then out west you
got teams at the top of the west really
scuffling because the suns have no chris
paul the warriors have no draymond green
and you know and so there's a little
vulnerability there and here come teams
like denver minnesota
now it would be perfect if the clippers
were getting kawhi leonard and paul
george back but that's not happening um
but there's just dangerous teams on the
second half of the west kind of top ten
so it's just so different rich
than all those years in recent history
when we were kind of just waiting for
the cavs and the warriors to meet in the
finals again you know like this this
entire stretch feels very relevant and
there's plenty to keep track of every
single night so you're saying my having
mike malone is my first guest tomorrow
is a timely guest especially what you're
saying timely guess just don't call him
mike don't forget you got to call him
michael michael phone
michael
malone i am making that
note don't you remember did you not see
when he uh he kind of got on uh cassidy
hubbard at of espn for calling him mike
during her in-game interview with him um
i will call him michael malone and uh
thank you samuel i appreciate the time
to help you yes thank god richard you
make me better thank you very much sam
take care
appreciate it see you there's sam eric
of the athletic hey you watched all the
way to the end thanks for that watch
more right here